dynasty will be forever remembered as
the ultimate 80s soap opera and eternal
into Evans into one of TV's biggest
stars but that was nearly 30 years ago
and the last decade has been far from
glamorous for Linda a debilitating
illness severe depression at one point
Linda even thought about taking her own
life now this seems impossible to
imagine but it is all in her book and
Linda walk me through how her world
completely crumbled my life just fell
apart I didn't understand depression and
my blood pressure went up it just became
a nightmare as many as 21 million a week
tuned into those legendary cat fights
between Crystal and Alexis but almost
two decades after her dynasty run ended
Linda's downward spiral began when three
people she loved dearly suddenly faced
serious health issues I had never been
in this situation where so many people I
loved we're having so much trouble what
were some of the toughest times when I
was to take blood pressure medicine and
they didn't like the way it made me feel
I stopped and I was out aside and
blanked out just blacked out next thing
I was facedown on the gravel and I just
got up and my face was bloody and I went
oh my god what just happened to me and I
realized I just needed help to help pull
herself out of the depression Linda
wrote a book that she's just updated
recipes for Life Park cookbook art
memoir friends said you had to do
something that makes you happy I said
food makes me happy there's even a
chapter that mentions ET filming her
after a flight with the Blue Angels more
MORE
I got to tell you something tell me I
was so sick when I got off that plane
which I didn't want to admit to you guys
but just three years ago Linda was
struck with a sickness much more severe
a sudden onset of back pain so
excruciating she considered suicide I
really understood why people said maybe
I don't need to be alive because it's so
painful to be alive and nobody had an
answer were the times where you thought
about that I mean it's
absolutely I said there has to be an
answer this is not living cortisone
treatments led to hair loss a shock to
this woman whose big hair was once
copied by stylists everywhere this is
not my hair
this is a wig this is a wig because my
hair fell out Linda has been pain-free
for a year now after a laser procedure
and her hair will grow back and in the
meantime I just go fine it's okay see
the hiding is the part that's off like
we're ashamed of something shamed or
that I survived my back no I have a
warrior